here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay first question Billy
Crystal who more than anyone has
inspired or influenced your comedy Bill
Cosby
really yes because he he spoke he just
spoke to us he told us stories you know
I talked about him and in my show I mean
he had brothers I had brothers he played
football at Temple I belonged to a
temple so there was but he was Bill was
the most relaxed comic and he and we he
became a mentor to me he started took
him took me under my under his wing when
I was just starting out he'd show up at
little clubs I was playing in the
village and take me out and talk to me
about it and he said a very interesting
thing never catch them never let them
catch you working yeah that was his that
was his big never let him write how'd
you work and just talk and then and I
think that's that's a big thing George
Bush felt that way
don't feed your tweets and and yeah I
mean and you have like him you have
found ways to stay in the game like I
mean you're 65 as you're bragging about
now as usual you're in a major motion
picture just a few months ago I remember
that one you did with Julia Roberts was
a cold America merica sweethearts love
that movie it's a funny memory took my
mother to see then you wrote it right
yes and like you you modulated from the
leading man you're like now I'm older
I'm gonna give myself the secondary role
and I'm getting it right a great part
for Julia Roberts you know how to stay
in the game I'm gonna be here when
you're ready fire oh yeah and I'm
looking forward to playing my my age
jockey role yeah you know that right the
Mickey Rhodey black stallion but you
know that's Susan one forty five fifty
she's a beauty I'm gonna sleep in a barn
with his head okay she's got a little
fever she looks shiny ok David from
why do you think medical marijuana is as
you say a laughable fiction oh because
it's nothing medical about that many no
some people absolutely have gotten
relief in ways they never had before you
know that's true the numbers aren't
vanishingly small and when you look at
what so it is true that the state of
Colorado I think it's like 2% of medical
marijuana prescriptions are for cancer
and 1% are for HIV in count here in
California what about anything we're
banning noise yeah we're chronic chronic
back pain that is what the prescriptions
are written for and they're written by
doctors who don't meet their patients
who are handful of doctors waiting as if
thousands so you don't think it should
be legal I don't think it should be
legal why what's wrong with I think we
make we have we put out enough snares
and traps for people I see I I see it as
I what I see it as in yes and it didn't
work for you it did that's why I'm
against it what if they genetically
modify it will you like
it's the government's job to tell the
people what's right for them it's just
as it just as it we at the government we
have we have government that inspects
whether your credit-card contract is
abusive we have government that inspects
whether you're sort of but what your
cable touch whether your cell phone
bills are abusive that one one of the
ways that has to do with what I couldn't
I mean you're all for the privacy and
what could be more private than what
goes on in my own head I am somewhat I
was a speak for my politics not for
other people's I am concerned that we
are getting better and better and better
at writing off people who are dealt an
unlucky hand at the beginning of life
and just I mean the marijuana may not
have done you any harm but it's done a
lot of other people harm and you and you
would be fine you know the questions are
we gonna run society in such a way that
makes it more convenient for you who's
going to be great anyway or whether we
do a little bit more protection
[Applause]
[Laughter]
boy that was a slowest quarter she
instruction you know but even if you
could do this which I don't think it
could or why's the drug war we've tried
it for 40 years doesn't we're not
winning the natural lottery and are born
in to prevent in too bad sir yes the
drug war is hammering them and has been
hammering this yeah that's I'm not I I
am very happy that Americans drink a lot
less but should we get rid of it I mean
you're saying with should be illegal
when you would have a certainly alcohol
was way more harm for the people
certainly we should have make that
illegal for the people most likely to
abuse alcohol 18 to 21 year olds it is
now illegal okay but what about the rest
of the people who abuse it also those
are the people who are really no one has
ever been able to answer that conundrum
if marijuana is illegal then obviously
the one that's even more harmful should
be illegal to every other drug in our
society we're moving in the in the
direction of greater another question
should we make alcohol illegal again if
thought is I don't think we should make
I don't think we should send people to
jail for smoking marijuana and I don't
think we should ban alcohol but we did
ban alcohol from people 18 to 21 in the
middle 80s and that has had a huge
impact on auto safety it's had a huge
impact on reduction in alcoholism we've
made a lot of social progress okay okay
all right
I love the frustration and feistiness
you've shown Chris Hayes is there a
specific issue that drives it well you
know I think I think that I find myself
in a situation which I want to have you
don't want to be a closed-minded jerk
just because you have a strong beliefs
or worldview and you also don't want to
reduce your ideological enemies to
caricatures and yet there you know there
are certain things like voting to cut
forty billion dollars in the food stamps
program after they cleaved off the bill
so that they could have a special vote
in which they voted to stuff government
money in the pockets of large farm
interests including members of Congress
themselves there's a member of Congress
in Tennessee who has gotten far
subsidies himself okay he voted to keep
sending farm subsidies and then a few
weeks later voted to take money out of
the hands and food out of the hands of
poor people and you hit some point where
you're just a little staring into the
some moral abomination that that that
doesn't allow you to feel particularly
charitable or open mind
what do you think about Jazeera America
so far you're speaking to me has anyone
seen it no I worked for them that's
right that's right
well Al Gore owned Current TV and then
he sold it to this Arab country that
basically has a lot of oil I think so it
was a little odd I got it cutter yeah
but they were very nice to me my boss
went from Al Gore to Ahab and Mosta and
then I left then that was it right but
they were very nice it's a tough
marketing so it's like I remember there
used to be a candy called AIDS oh yeah
remember a white I remember I would love
to be at that meeting after the AIDS
virus hit fellas we are gonna have to
completely rethink how we sell our
product the road here there was a
dietary candy it was a dietary yeah you
see my point the UN happiness index
lists Canada Denmark Norway Switzerland
the Netherlands Sweden and Finland the
happiest countries what does it say to
the panel that only one North American
country is on the list Billy Crystal
I've been in Finland Finland yes that is
not a happy
yes why we wanna press I was coming back
through Russia and you come back for
Laughs through Finland it's dark at noon
right yeah Herring's at each other
bye-bye
how is that a happy country have the
Swedes tell a joke about the Finn's and
this is this is sweeter chef Nikki where
did the sweet how did he looks at your
shoes when he's talking to you would
Bill Maher in Friday night at 10 past
bill and his guests who are questions
right after the show
at hbo.com